there is a cautious calm in
rebel-controlled southern idlib and
northern hama
russian and syrian warplanes have been
repeatedly targeting towns like marat no
man for the past three months
a ceasefire that came into effect on
friday night has brought
some respite for people living in that
corner of northwest syria
who have lost so much money
after all that happened isn't it too
late for a ceasefire
people have been displaced killed their
homes destroyed
but they are still scared to return to
their homes
more than 400 000 syrians have been
displaced at least 800 civilians were
killed
their names documented by war monitors
among the casualties
216 children but the syrian government
and its allies
failed to recapture ground from the
opposition
the russians with all their power were
not able to make any gains
along with the syrian regime they lost a
lot of men
they were only able to take two or three
villages
that's why they wanted the ceasefire on
the ground we are stronger
it proved to be a costly battle for the
syrian government and its allies who
reportedly suffered heavy losses
in their ranks the cease-fire was
brokered by the backers of the
opposition and the government turkey and
russia but it is a conditional truce
that puts pressure on turkey
to create a demilitarized zone around
the idlib province
free of weapons and fighters in line
with the so-called
sochi memorandums the mainstream rebel
factions left their positions in the
planned
zone last year but the strongest group
hayatahri rashem
which many in the international
community believe is still linked to
al-qaeda
refused it hasn't said if it will comply
this time there's a huge challenge for
both sides for turkey to implement the
sochi agreement
to force the radicals out of the
demonstration zone and for russia to
stop the assad regime which it can't
couldn't do before so i personally think
that there is
a huge challenge and the risk is high
that there will be a new escalation
actually
the syrian opposition believes the
government will eventually violate the
ceasefire
and the bombing will resume if not in a
few hours then in a few weeks
or a few months idlib's fate is up to
russia and turkey
they still want to maintain close
relations and as long as their
geopolitical
interests are aligned the conditions
attached to the ceasefire
may be overlooked senator al jazeera
gaziantep